it seems like we are back in the Cold
War war era and it shows in the economy
I will discussing the unfolding crisis
in Crimea and the global economic
situation with Oliver Morocco of
Deutsche Bank research mr. Rocco you are
looking at the numbers each month em
what do the numbers tell you about the
March what how did the d-backs develop
the divx was stable and the stable on a
pretty solid level actually and was
driven by an improvement in the United
States on the other hand in Germany or
Europe the indicators we are looking at
actually fell a bit not bad but also not
great and in Japan the final part of the
divx the index actually increased a bit
and so far a solid result for March but
not spectacular what's causing the
decline in Germany that's difficult to
assess right now we are hesitant to put
it on to Russia and the cranium crisis
it's possible that it's included in the
deterioration and these sentiment
indicators however so far we would still
judge it to be due to seasonal factors
we had a very mild winter and now we
have some normalization of sentiment
data and so far we are not really
concerned yet in that regard how could
the current conflict with Russia affect
their global economic upswing what do
you think well it really depends on how
far sanctions are going from the United
States and from Europe currently at
least and the sanctions are not
materially enough to really affect a
global growth only if a lot more
sanctions would be put in place or if
Russia for example would stop exporting
oil or gas these are scenarios that
would actually affect the global economy
but we are not really seeing that right
now and so far it might weigh a bit on
global growth but the question is if
it's really a calculable and how much
that is in addition to this conflict
with Russia there's another serious
threat in Europe it's
leyshon so the prices and the demand
could be lower and lower so what do you
think is this really something that
could threaten the European economy
right now it's a real threat that's true
it's a risk we have right now in Europe
but we would still judge it to be a low
risk not a lot of certainty around that
and especially given the fact that the
decline in price we are currently
observing is largely driven from
external factors if you look if you try
to avoid this looking at the energy
prices and food prices if you take that
out of the development actually prices
have been stable over the last couple of
months on a low level that is true so
there is a risk but we would still judge
it to be relatively low but we have to
look at the next couple of month okay
thank you so far mr. Rocco and we will
talk about this topic further on
nightmare deflation is here this the
European economy threatened so you can
watch the full interview on GW de /
english / made in germany